ladies and gentlemen here are farad and
Herold the Nicholas brother
thank you huh thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen you know 50 years ago I
was never out of breath
well fifty years ago you were never
other splits either well hell yeah we
have had the opportunity to dance to
some of the best music to come out of
this town right on now we're going to
present the award for the best original
score' mm-hmm and it's a great honor
indeed I know the nominees are John
Corigliano hmm four altered states
mm-hmm very good John Morris for the
Elephant Man John Williams for the
Empire Strikes Back
Michael Gore for fame oh yes
and Phillip Saad Fortis please please
get the envelope take it too long and
the winner is mm-hmm
when you gonna get one of these oh well
maybe something yeah
oh yes can't be too late Oh the winner
is Michael Gore for fame
well this is incredible
I'd like to thank the members of the
Academy for this honor there was so many
people involved in creating the music
for fame from my collaborators being
Pitchford my sister Leslie Gore to
literally hundreds of musicians and
performers I'd like to thank them all in
addition I'd like to thank MGM our
producer Alan Marshall for his constant
support and enthusiasm throughout the
production and most of all Alan Parker
for making Fame one of the best
experiences of my life thank you very
much